so when is the last time you actually
wrote something down if you're like me
brian always teases me you just dictate
it into your phone you're very good at
that i did do a shopping list today but
a lot of people it's texts and emails
voice messages and zooms but not for
everyone john langler introduces us to a
group of women trying to preserve the
art of writing
so i'm going to write your name with one
blank sheet of paper
nancy sampson opens an entire world it's
the tools and the practice that make it
beautiful
it's a world of history and art nimble
hands and steady patience i can write a
hand that they used in the 400s the
practice of calligraphy calligraphy is
not quick she picked it up almost 40
years ago now as most of the world texts
and emails its way through the day
samson works on this craft it's an
expression and she's not the only one
this is
faux calligraphy and i love it these are
the fabulous las vegas scribes a club
for calligraphy when things are
neat and tidy and colorful and balanced
i get great joy from it they meet every
few months honing their handwriting
last weekend they gathered in person for
the first time since the pandemic
started yeah i like that working and
collaborating on all sorts of art yeah
yeah yeah that's really nice i started
doing calligraphy
30 years ago and so
it becomes just some writing on an
envelope and you just want to do more
it's not that they don't appreciate how
we communicate these days after all we
set this story up through email not with
courier pigeons it's beautiful handmade
artwork but the scribes feel like that
skill of handwriting and that art of
calligraphy it's slowly getting lost
this is an expression this is creative
this is a flourish i think history is
important we don't want to lose our
history with each stroke the scribes
hope to save it it is a fading skill and
it shouldn't be
john langler 8 news now
it's really beautiful writing yeah the
only time i usually see it is like on a
wedding invitation or something my dad
used to do it for birthday cards and
stuff
it's kind of it's good to see that story
from john we got to bring that back got
to keep it alive